Let's see the simplex algorithm
in action on an example
from the first part of the lesson.
I've changed the variable
names here a little bit.
So we'll let x1 correspond to the number
of minutes spent doing step aerobics,
and we'll let x2 correspond to
the number of minutes spent stretching.
I've also introduced a slack variable,
x3, on this constraint for
the length of the workout.
And a surplus variable, x4, for
how many minutes of extra stretching
that our actor decides to do.
And together, these allow me to trade
the inequality constraints we had before
for equality constraints.
Let's suppose that our current
solution is down here in this corner,
meaning that x1 is 0, x2 is 5.
And our slack variable here will be 35,
and our surplus variable here will be 0.
The basic variables here are clearly
x2 and x3, and the sub matrix
B of the constraint matrix A consists
of these two columns here.
Recall that we want to solve for
these basic variables and
essentially eliminate them.
And here, we see that we have x2 =
x4 + 5, from this equation here.
And x3 then must be 35
minus x1 minus x4, and
of course,
these need to remain non-negative.
Substituting these into
the objective function,
I now get this in terms of
the non-basic variables,
the ones that I'm thinking about
moving into the basis, x1 and x4.
And actually, both of these have
positive entries in the rd matrix.
rd here just has 12 and
4 as its coefficients.
Well, arbitrarily, we'll go ahead and
choose x4 as the variable
to bring into the basis.
So essentially,
x1 gets automatically set to 0, and
these here then become the constraints.
The negative sign here means that I
could send x4 as big as I wanted to,
and that wouldn't affect
this constraint at all.
Here however, the coefficient on x4
is positive, so we do need to worry
about this constraint, and that
limits how much bigger I can make x4.
Only up to 35.
The fact that this constraint goes
tight implies that x3 became 0.
So x3 should go out of the basis and
x4 should come in.
Graphically, this corresponds to moving
from this point down here to this one up
here, with these being the new
values for my x variables.
And then I would repeat this process for
the new basis, and
eventually come down this edge
here to the optimal solution.